product not yet rated  you  Harken a convicted villain a stain on  humanity and yet now the world's only  hope the evil rogue are led by the  Lord's have raided the human realm the  keystone monastery is in grave danger  only evil can destroy evil of the  world's only answer is a harken  enter the realm of the rogue ah harken  enter through the abandoned temple hunt  down all the wards of the raiding army  and harken find out the truth about the  war  there is no single end to your journey  this is not a war which only one side  wins witness both worlds Hawking travel  across dimensions seek out the sinister  the far more sinister than you uncover  the hidden secrets then for world's fate  awaits a fate harken you decide  pre-order now to receive the  an upgrade in America's only